ce qui m'a is disent toujours
tonia dit la vérité ça existe pas la
vérité tout le monde a sa propre vérité
j'étais la meilleure patineuse
artistique du monde pendant un moment
c'est ce que tu appelles patiner portait
pas de gros mots dans les enfants rien
dit de mal connaître
vous avez déjà baiser on veut quelqu'un
qui vient d'une famille avec de bonnes
valeurs morales vient pas d'une famille
avec des bonnes valeurs mrad avait
autant grâce que bruce lesbiennes
j'avais honte pour toi j'ai passé ma vie
à faire dire que je n'arriverai jamais à
rien
et vous savez quoi
c'est peut-être faut parfois pour avoir
débauché jo si la présentation sous ce
mois là tu vas falloir égalisé les
chances âge connais un gars dont je
devrais même pas dire le nom d'eric les
médias voulaient me faire passer pour un
tas de merde j'ai jamais fait ça
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui se passe on est du fbi
cherche quelque chose
que pouvez-vous nous dire sur togneri
jusqu'à les pas de tony vous n'êtes pas
son garde du corps
[Musique]
quand j'étais petit as tu déjà aimé gp
doit une championne dans sachant qu
mailleraye pour ça et c'est un sacrifice
qu'on fait qu'en mer sont à porter
malheur les genres ils veulent quelqu'un
à aimer mais ils veulent surtout
quelqu'un à haïr
je veux dire quand même quel genre de
foutus débile démolirait le genou d'une
de ses amies
qui voudrait faire ça à une amie
lâche moi